[Music]
in loophole backfired news committed by
your mom your mom oh really
my mom she's watching Jeff something in
your mouth Joe know a guy who tried to
prank the DMV wound up with thousands of
tickets I like this story I need more
information I understand what I mean me
neither
all right so this guy he's a hacker he
was at this hacking conference in Vegas
where he talked about don't call him the
screen is up okay I didn't know they had
hacking consciousness I thought supposed
to be on the down-low Def Con we
actually know one of the guys that used
to run it he recently passed away rest
in peace homeboy oh this guy his name is
drew key drew key is his handle and so
he was saying that he registered for a
vanity license plates in California and
he he registered it as null so n ull
which looks like you know like nothing
like neither yeah so he thought that he
was gonna be invisible that whenever
like if he would ever get a ticket or
something you would just go undetected
in the system because it's null but it
ended up backfiring or actually so when
he went so he had a whole year and it
was great when he had to register his
license plate
I could rear edge astir his tags that's
when there was a pretty much said that
he couldn't renew it like online renew
his registration so he was like oh man
all right but then all of a sudden he
started getting all these tickets
because there's this citation processing
center this is like privately-owned and
it had a database of outstanding tickets
and in their database whenever there was
an incomplete license plate or
information it would show up as null so
all those tickets for those other people
yeah so she ended up having over a
$12,000 worth of
oh so he trotted himself pretty much so
you could even completed registration
because all you got to pay all these
[ __ ] tickets for exactly how do you
prove that's not you that's so crazy so
he ended up talking to DMV and you can't
even talk to her DMV to be honest yeah
she had to wait like six months for the
appointment to finally our appointments
coming up I'm excited okay you're
excited about a DMV appointment for a
motorcycle license
oh isn't that exciting mm-hmm-hmm so
then he contacted the DMV and the LAPD
and he explained the situation but they
both told him the same thing which was
just change your plates like you're
gonna keep having this problem they were
able to so Danby was able to contact
that private citation processing company
and they did erase the $12,000 and fines
well just so nice of them but it didn't
fix the problem in their system because
he's still getting new tickets oh that's
his fault now well no he's saying I
didn't do anything wrong you know with
any hack into the system to get it no
you didn't hack in he was just thinking
that this was like a loophole by getting
the vanity plate no but he's not doing
it wrong but he's a little [ __ ] yeah I
mean I mean I wouldn't say that you
could hack into your [ __ ] conquers a
little bit
wait so where's the Hat what's where's
that hacking code so the hacking is how
we found out about this story which was
at the hacking convention where he was
talking about this and I think he's
trying to hack the system we're like
okay if it usually fits like 5xw
whatever yeah that's when they scan it
they could send a ticket to your house
but if it's null that's already telling
whatever the scanner this license plate
doesn't exist so if you think he's
flying under the radar he's more like a
life hack than the computer hack
yeah yeah yeah well in this case yeah
thank you but at the hacking convention
they just hack everything to or like
it's it's just everything planned hacked
life hack whatever they hack each other
they have they have a game actually
we're like it's kind of like they go
through and hacking battle yeah hacking
battles that's [ __ ] fun I should
learn
HAC but like not to doing I went to one
of these conventions because my buddy
was DJing and in Vegas and we were both
kind of like 17 18 at the time like they
said you guys are kind of 17 yeah yeah
we were like around that age but then we
didn't want to drive there so his buddy
took us there but his buddy was going to
this convention oh this one yeah and in
so like you think he'll a nerdy right
but there's a lot of guys that actually
work for like government and all this
stuff that they're hackers but this is
their like fun [ __ ] or like some guys
would you know they would hack but then
they they work for these agencies - they
have different terms like white hack I
mean what a gray hat yeah black hat
whatever yeah bad huh dad hat don't work
with those yeah but when you go there
it's like any other convention like it's
it's got booths people selling [ __ ] like
there's like do they have girl I didn't
see Ikea that is the biggest company of
the year that's been hacked or Equifax
whoever hacked Aquifer yeah maybe they
get an award that's that's pretty
valiant Best Supporting haka goes to I'm
sure there's a lot of novelty happy sack
oh yeah the 2019 award goes to the guy
who hacked the FBI and in the [ __ ]
FBI comes a guy the television yeah it
was cool cuz like you go there in a day
time and it's just you just think it's
gonna be all nerds just like they're
selling shirts funny like that the
winner there were DIY hack the winner of
the award of skype sin and you hear like
something thank you some guy from
Jeffery Epstein's Island just so that at
night it was [ __ ] crazy because like
you would expect it to be just hella
nerdy 24/7 and at night it was just a
[ __ ] ton of just strippers there at the
conventions with money will probably get
stripped I just picture that they turned
into a big [ __ ] party and they hired
a [ __ ] ton of strippers to come into the
convention hall there's a deejay
in a way that I was like strippers
aren't a hacky Oh I was like if I'm a
nerd I'm in Vegas
I got money yes Ramona fellow with
strippers I get it but in my mind I'm
thinking they're they're so into hacking
that it's like get the [ __ ] away from me
girls because you know like video games
and then the girls are like standing if
all of them like their girlfriends
trying to [ __ ] them and they're like get
the [ __ ] with that one uh with Ryan
Philippe where he had to hack into
something while a girl was sucking his
dick
that was a huge Ackman yeah swordfish
swordfish he's like let me just pus real
quick
and get her out of the way so I can
finish my and so I actually know one of
the guys recently he told me that he
used to use to throw this event the DEF
CON event back in the day he was in
charge of doing it him in one of his
partners his partners is like a hardcore
[ __ ] hacker when they threw the event
the FBI came looking for him oh the
whole time like they're just radioing in
with all of their friends and [ __ ] they
like where they at okay and they're
moving him from room to room playing
cat-and-mouse throughout the whole
convention like that's [ __ ] crazy
dude you think the strippers they were
there you know if they were hackers to
think it was hacking your bank account
and steal at one dollar at a time
oh that's kind of genius take that out
no that's genius there is a guy that
actually got in trouble for like a penny
or something yeah yeah an office space
yeah I can obviously the remainder of
the cent
yeah and then you just slowly accumulate
millions of dollars it's like oh it's
not like operation piggy bank or
something like that oh my god how cute
this is an actual thing you ever seen a
movie office space yeah so like the the
hack was that like every time every
every time like every time money gets
put in this account there's like half a
cent left over and it rounds off to the
nearest cent half a cent goes into a
secret account so over time you know and
we just add up to
every transaction you'd be like fraction
of a cent yeah that was a good movie
that's one of my favorite yeah the guy
with the red stapler everything my
stapler I saw the guy at some restaurant
at Terminix the guy that played the main
guy yes for some reason I'm so full of
coffee I can't remember his name and the
move Peter the main character in office
space
he hasn't really done too many movies
after that he was also in Sex in the
City
oh yeah he was a character in that show
too he was in one others couldn't name
it his real name do you see a lot of
celebrities in your neighborhood
he's like more the only ones Oh cuz that
when I saw him I was like oh [ __ ] is
Peters he's gonna go crazy like he did
in office space is he gonna flip the
table up and say [ __ ] life I like the
guy that was named Michael Bolton
Michael no I gotta go by Mike he's one
it sucks
yeah way see the guy that likes hip-hop
yeah yeah like in the morning don't want
my favorite scene yeah you ever worked
in the office like a cubicle time if
you've ever worked in a cubicle office
type of situation it's the best
yes movie it's so accurate it's like the
office before the office yeah just
recently Casey I just I don't know Danny
try how even it well enough no no it's
just recently you can walk in here right
now back I'm like what's up Casey and I
had a conversation where I was like I
remember someone told me that Danny
Trejo is always in Venice and they live
there so I thought it was you do it in
Venice
I used to where you look now Sherman
Oaks Oh che we're neighbors oh you how
did you get here on time I left a little
early on purpose how's the first person
here yeah what time do you leave I
thought I was in the wrong places I went
to the front there's a door like go the
[ __ ] away and then I go to the back of
the door let's go the [ __ ] away
legit what time did you leave though you
probably wanted to be like I love that
7:45 and I was still 10 minutes later
like 7:35 well that makes sense cuz I
was 10 minutes late and he was on time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]